Sir, for $10,000,
name a manly thing that Donald Trump has done.
Nothing manly. Please.
What is your name? King.
No, I really can't.
Does it exist? Who is this Rudy poo?
Shoot socials. What? Tanking? Exactly.
That's what I thought, you overgrown 500 pound bag of monkey crap.
See? What?
Three times? I'm sorry,
my parents are business owners.
They've declared bankruptcy.
What? Zero.
An elder manly thing? Maybe like shit his pants
maybe. Peace.
Standing up. You're talking about Kelsey.
What about the fact that he spends more time blending his concealer
than crafting form policy?
I don't think he does. He does not know how to properly blend.
Haha,
maybe that is the most manly thing
is that he doesn't know how to blend his makeup.
No, no,
this is My Pretty Pony. Don't touch my Pretty Pony.
It's my sister's. Okay,
just name a manly thing that Donald Trump has done.
I'll get back to you.